we've talked about various aspects of
bootstrapping a lot on computer file
going way back I think to a ton robin
video three or four years ago now which
is doing very well
dilemma of the chicken and the egg he
talks very well about the essential
nature of bootstrapping and so on but he
very carefully avoids going into detail
because it does get complicated the way
I've always found best to teach it is to
use a tool called T diagrams which you
just draw for yourself I'm going to
explain via diagrams what it means to
bootstrap bootstrap a system like an
assembler or a compiler or whatever but
first of all what is a t diagram draw me
a t diagram let us assume that you have
written a program in Bell lab C language
you are very very proud of this program
you think is absolutely wonderful and
will win an award and all that this is
the input to your program this is the
output from your program and at this
level I can say what does that mean it
means that the program was written in
I've chosen C deliberately because it's
low level it's fairly close to the
hardware something like this I hope
you'll all recognize you're writing a
simple program in a simple language and
you're delighted when you're high level
statements produce ultimately this thing
I will try not to fall back into a
cheese usage and say it produces a core
image they even call it that's about as
no it's an executable
okay well we all know that it's all very
well saying our right agency is gonna
have this input it will produce that
output the next question is but how do
you convert the C into a runnable
executable binary which will be your
program you have to get that C
translated and here you begin to see the
power of T diagrams draw this one again
input/output it's written in C
now here's the clever that positioning
another T block like that up against
this one shows you how this has to be
processed what you need is something
that will turn you'll see program
statements into a working binary on the
machine you're working on you may say
mmm but where did this come from
somebody provided me with a thing that
is capable of taking in C statements is
is itself an executable binary it's
running on my arm chip on my Intel on my
Apple or whatever this is my C compiler
of course there's got to have come from
somewhere but we'll get into that later
so there's the C compiler and if you
feed the C language for your master
program through that compiler you know
what happens it produces an a dot out on
UNIX or an executable binary the net
effect of slotting that T diagram
against here slightly downwards is to
show you that the C you've written gets
converted into binary and the net output
from this process it produces out a
program that you probably store in a
file somewhere which is like this
left-hand side only a little bit
different because it's now input/output
but look what has happened during the
compilation process is that by compiling
your C statements for your program it
drinks the minutes data the compiler
itself is a binary running on your
architecture that you're perfectly happy
with it is squirting out executable
binary so I can write in here let's say
that's my output binary code but that
output binary code I'll stick with a
pink our right bin in here to show you
that that is what the compiler has done
for you
you think of it as input producing
output and I wrote it in C and you close
your eyes as to what happens it just
works but your binary your a dot out
your ultimate executable will tell your
input will produce perfect out put first
time of course but it is essentially
written in binary and has to be to
execute directly
the hardware that has been produced by
AC compiler and the T diagram for C
compiler is this
I accept as input C I am a runnable
binary otherwise I won't work at all but
I have code generation capabilities i
generate binary that will run and that
is your user executable and here's the
first point I want to make the quality
of the binary that actually is your
compiler running may be very different
from the quality of the binary that it
spits out as a translation of your
program they may be very similar or it
could be that the C compiler is actually
very very slow at producing your output
binary but if he gets there in the end
you don't care it could be ultra fast it
could be that you've written a see
compilers are so bad that the output
that it produces for you is worse than
it itself is using I hope you all get
the hang here there's not necessarily
any direct link between the quality of
the binary you are running to make the C
compiler work as opposed to the binary
it is spitting out for your program has
its translation they may be related and
may be close and all this what I think
now I will try and do for you is to take
the story one stage backwards and start
speculating about how the heck did I get
the C compiler is it something that 10
Thompson handed over or Dennis Ritchie
hand it over to me already made it could
have been oh you might say Dennis how
did you implement that to C compiler and
he was so well the first version I wrote
off the back of an assembler and of
course this it goes on recursively
forever but Dennis who wrote the
assembler you know and back and back and
back right down to squirting ones and
zeros in on hand kids no let's presume
for the next stage of the story that
from somewhere your little machine did
also come with an assembler for
low-level programming
for filling in the bits that may be the
C compiler for one reason or another
isn't suitable for well how is that done
in T diagram terms and by looking at how
the assembler is done we can then see
how it's possible to bootstrap off an
assembler version of something to a
higher-level version an assembler is
like a compiler except for those of you
who've done it you know in every sense
an assembler is at a lower level
assembler some particular macro
assemblers they'll give you a vestigial
capability to do an array but they may
not have structures almost certainly
won't they're a high level constructs
you see so you you're down with simple
add subtract statements you can move
about memory you've got to understand
pointers we've done lots of those you do
them at the assembler level you're in
charge you must keep track of what your
pointers are in so on and so on and so
on
it's just a simpler view of the world
and a more detailed and complicated one
in several ways I'll call it AC and that
stands for assembler input now you
expect that assembler to produce you a
runnable executable binary well I'm
going to write this in here as saying
that the code generation from the
assembler is going to produce me what
I'll call a binary of type a is produced
from an assembler it's an assembler
quality binary it depends on the Koho
wrote the code generator for the
assembler as to how good that being a is
now here's the thing again you'll have
to get your head round and get used to
this is au been you I don't know how
this was developed this assembler all I
know is I met Ken in the corridor David
wheeler it came to the corridor and said
hey here's the assembler I use they
handed over an executable and I did not
ask questions about how that in itself
may have been bootstrapped out of
nothing
they just said here's an assembler it
works use it so okay I say thank you I
mean at the midpoint of a endless
sequence of bootstrapping but I can
build on top of an sm
to build the C compiler shall we say so
you put assembler codes in of course the
unknown provenance binary is worrying
away and that is executing the assembler
code and out it comes as binary of type
a which you can put in a file BN a dot
out file under you mix it could be
whatever you can store it in a file you
can invoke it you can execute it and the
only difference from what's gone before
is that the assembler code is it's a
lower sophistication level than you'll
see you would be a lot of you know again
I keep harking back to Bell Labs history
largely because it's very good for
illustrating this thing you can say look
this really happened this really is what
Dennis inten did this is what you have
to be aware of Dennis said you can and
cancers to Dennis for the next version
of the UNIX operating system we've gotta
write it in something higher level
it drives you mad writing it in
assembler because there's no easy way of
keeping track of pointers there's no
structures in fact in a recent video now
out there in the wild somewhere ken
Thompson admits he said our first three
attempts to write UNIX in a higher-level
language and Dennis was developing say
the first three attempts I tried I'm Ken
Thompson failed why did they fail I
found later the fourth attempt Dennis
had put structures in C and that's what
I needed because they automatically keep
track of offsets and pointers wonderful
okay so here we are then back in that
kind of era we are wanting to create a C
language compiler but we are writing it
as a simpler code level it is going to
produce a binary but going back to what
we said last time because it came out of
an assembler era we're going to presume
that the binary that this thing produces
is what we'll call binary a it came via
an assembler
did this execute them fine but then you
look at that say hey come on this is
brushing over certain details you can't
directly execute assembler and unless
somebody's written an assembler
interpreter for you but they're again
no they haven't that's emblem coding
it's got to be converted into a binary
how do you turn the assembler coding
into a binary and so sort up another T
diagram and visualize what goes on there
just happens to be hanging around
because Ken gave it to us in the
corridor a thing called an assembler and
the assembler accepts any old assembler
code you like produces what we'll call
been a an executable binary but it came
out of an assembler and that the
assembler itself the binary is of
unknown provenance candidate in absolute
binary off the top of his head probably
not but somebody labored long and hard
to write a thing that really works as an
assembler on this particular machine
that you are working on what you need to
do is to feed the assembler code that
implements your C compiler into the
assembler itself to assemble it you've
got to assemble the assembly code that
is the compiler and it goes in as
assembler coding it's running on its own
binary you're thinking a while' crash no
it won't Ken wrote it you know this sort
of thing that was around and it converts
the assembler code into binary of
quality a that binary of quality a when
it's produced you can store in a file
it's an executable it's an a dot out
file and then you have created a thing
which takes in C produces binary a
assembler coding so your net output here
then is the following
it's C it spits out an executable binary
for you the C compiler so we now have a
C compiler that is not just as it were
implemented at the assembly code level
but that assembly code has been
translated into a binary so that the C
compiler can actually run on
hardware and once again there's trace
through the assembler code that
implements the C compiler is fed into
the assembler this thing was round and
round like mad but the assembler code
statements that are the compiler get
translated into bin of quality a and
that's the implementation vehicle for
your new C compiler you have produced a
C compiler by building it out of an
assembler by using the assembler as the
next stage long which you have to do the
assembler converts the assembler code
that is the C compiler into being a
workable runnable binary of quality a so
that's the first start of your compiler
is to say we we doing bootstrapping
we've come up off an assembler solution
we wrote in our high-level language and
here we are a very very first C compiler
is there a problem with it not really
except that what we want to do here is
to say well we want an AC compiler that
will produce runnable binary of some
sort and then we say hey but the only
tool we've got to making a binary for
this C compiler is that there is the
assembler itself right the assembler
produces Benet so you're stuck with that
so can you see that by running the
assembler there and making it squirt out
binary a quality equivalent to the
assembler code that is the compiler you
end up with AC compiler Marquand that
spits out Benet
but is running on Binet we're at the
mercy of bin of quality a the assembler
quality binary is it good is it bad
could we do better yeah we stop there
but just as a marker for what's coming
if your head isn't aching yet that thing
is building a compiler off an assembler
when that is working what do you do to
make it better you rewrite it and you
make a new version of a C compiler that
produces beam B which is
so binary but how do you compile a new
version of the C compiler answer with
the old one so you end up with a seat
have been better but it's still running
on Binet next time
I'd lost my compilers notes and
assembling those did you see diagrams
but thanks to one of my grad students
rom nots bless you Ron who was a
complete pack rat
he had rewritten all my notes in much
better shape and had come on to them
from 30-something years ago so I
couldn't made this video without your
own thank you very much